if you think you suck as you sit here
today I want you to understand something
that was somebody else's voice putting
that inside of your head most people are
in some version of an abusive
relationship with themselves yes Dave
insecurity for what as if not every
other person on Earth sucks at a lot of
things too we all suck at tons of [__]
stop putting others on a pedestal to
only undermine yourself when in essence
a parent likely put that insecurity
negative it into you like you don't hate
yourself as much as you think you don't
think you stink as much as you think you
are borrowing the words of something
that happened along the way and you are
capable right now to start the process
to not do that anymore you're worth it
it's worth it